if Batman is the hero Gotham deserves
hell I just feel sorry for Gotham
hello Internet
welcome to film theory where today's
episode is gonna get real not like
Hellmann's mayo real I mean comic book
movies getting real real seriously even
though it seems like it really shouldn't
matter whether comic book superhero
movies are realistic it's been all the
rage for literally the last decade and
it's made a huge difference the way we
see movies made about men and spandex
tights comic-book movies used to be the
center of everything cheesy campy and
overblown but now every time you turn
around there's another alcoholic Jessica
Jones or debate about the ethics of
Superman as a god-like being don't get
me wrong I enjoy it just that this stuff
is intense and at the center of it all
is Batman or should I say Batman that's
right gritty realism has been right next
to the batarangs and grappling hook on
Batman's tool belt
ever since Christopher Nolan's Dark
Knight trilogy took superhero movies
from this this and that's a good thing I
love The Dark Knight trilogy well most
of it anyway because simply put for
being the film's that defined what
realism means in comic book movies the
ending has a huge mistake a mistake that
puts Batman's hero status into serious
question from here on out hitch up your
spoiler pants because today we're
talking about the ending of the Dark
Knight Rises
at the end of the movie Batman stands
victorious Spain has been defeated and
Talia al Ghul has died her um dramatic
death only one major threat remains but
it's a doozy a nuclear bomb set to
flatten Gotham as the timer ticks down
Batman rushes to fly the bomb out over
the water to a safe distance where it
explodes city saved Batman is a hero
except that's actually not what would
happen if the movie was truly adhering
to realism as strictly as Christopher
Nolan intended Batman would actually
have failed in his attempt to say
the city let's look at the fast to show
you what I mean I have to tell you some
more about nuclear bombs I've actually
had the chance to visit one of the
world's real nuclear weapons sites in
Hiroshima do research for this kind of
episode and these weapons are incredibly
serious neutron bombs like the one shown
in Batman work by shooting incredibly
high-energy neutron particles to
specifically cause radiation damage to
know how strong a bomb is you look at
its yield which tells you how much
regular TNT it would take to achieve the
same blast as the bomb the neutron bomb
from Batman is a four kiloton weapon
meaning it would take 4,000 tons of tnt
to get the same blast that's 8 million
pounds of TNT to give you a comparison
the hore Oshima bomb was between 12.5
and 15 kilotons so this one is actually
quite a bit smaller about a third of the
size fun fact
or maybe not so fun fact believe it or
not there have been much much bigger
bombs made and tested over the years up
into the mega ton range a hundred times
the size of what was detonated over
Hiroshima so to the movie's credit it
actually does a good job of using a much
smaller bomb relative to how big these
things can get that being said though
they're still far from me letting them
off the hook the other thing about
neutron bombs that makes them special is
that they give off about 10 times the
neutron radiation of a fission bomb of
the same size that means that instead of
most of the bombs energy just being a
regular blast a lot more of it is
specifically radiation energy which is
longer-lasting and harder to contain so
even though the bat bomb is smaller than
say the bomb dropped on Hiroshima inside
the blast radius
uncontrollable radiation would make it
much more deadly so how big exactly is
that blast radius well the movie
actually tells us that it's six miles or
about twelve kilometers we know how far
we need to get the bomb away from every
other person to avoid major casualties
the end of the movie is trying to do
this when we see Batman tow the bomb out
to sea with his bat copter thing but
there are a lot of problems here the
first and most important is time let's
break it down when Batman attaches a
harness to the bomb we see that it has
one minute and 57 seconds left before
detonation then he wastes a bunch of
time macking on
selina kyle and having a heartfelt
goodbye with Commissioner Gordon
factoring in this hanger hanky pranky
into the countdown
he has just 75 seconds to get that bomb
as far away from Gotham as he possibly
can
so let's assess how he does let's assume
that Batman's bat copter is as fast as
the fastest helicopter in the world this
would make it the eurocopter x3 which
can achieve an absolute max flight speed
of 293 miles per hour it takes the
helicopter a minimum of 20 seconds to
achieve that max speed accepts even
though the eurocopter x3 is a really
fast helicopter Batman won't be flying
at top speed until he clears through the
buildings in the city you can even see
how he's slowly lifting the bomb up and
dragging it along the ground even having
to blow up and fly through buildings how
long does it take him to get out of the
city factoring in only the time we see
him flying on the screen it takes him 38
seconds to get out of Gotham who'll be
generous in our calculations here and
safe for that time he can fly at 50% of
his top speed I mean it's pretty clear
that he isn't going anywhere close to a
hundred and forty six miles per hour
half of our to 93 top speed since you
can see him struggling to lift the bomb
it's hitting things etc but hey we'll
give the guy a fighting chance
this leaves him with 37 seconds at top
speed beginning right here based on all
these factors and with the odds heavily
stacked in his favor the bat copter
would be able to fly only 3.1 miles away
from the city before detonating over the
water looking back at what the movie
tells us about the blast radius six
miles it's clear that Batman Batman it's
clear that Batman can't make it out far
enough to even save Gotham from the
basic blast
Batman is a very different type of
Supergirl let me reiterate our
assumptions here are really generous
when planes and helicopters are loaded
down they accelerate and fly a lot
slower remember that the bat copter
would be carrying a huge payload atomic
bombs typically weigh between 5 and 20
thousand pounds including their casing
and even though this bomb is small we
can expect it to easily clock in at
around 3,000 pounds weight that we
weren't factoring into the calculations
at all that kind of weight isn't too
heavy for the eurocopter x3 based on its
tech specs but it's over a third of its
total capacity
meaning that it would definitely slow
down the flight based on weight and wind
resistance but okay let's take it to the
extreme just for funsies let's see if
there was ever any chance of this
scenario being even a little bit
accurate because I like Batman and math
is fun let's assume that not only is the
bomb weightless the Batman hitches it to
his fastest in the world bat copter
already somehow going at top speed and
it doesn't take any additional time to
change the height of the helicopter in
the air if we basically ignore the laws
of physics to make all this happen you
come out with a different distance
salmon would be able to travel drumroll
please
6.1 miles offshore some days you just
can't get rid of a bomb technically just
edging out the main blast radius of the
bomb so I guess technically there was a
way to fake it to make it look like it
works even in this scenario not exactly
because the Batman bomb is a dirty bomb
and that means you need to factor in
radiation to understand what happens in
Gotham when the bomb doesn't make it out
of town we'll go back to our original
calculations where Batman makes it a
little more than three miles off the
coast to figure out what kind of damage
the bomb causes from there you have to
be clear about where Gotham is
technically it's a fictional location
but there are plenty of clues in the
Batman universe that give a good
indication of what real-life city it's
based on Gotham City is a nickname for
New York City first used back in 1807
Batman's writer bill finger also
originally meant for Batman's location
to be New York which is why he chose the
name Gotham and the city used as a
stand-in for Gotham in the Dark Knight
Rises is New York City and if that's not
enough evidence for you oh sorry jeez
face the facts it's true but okay fine
you can tell that this is specifically
Manhattan when you see Bane destroying
all the bridges into town I could go on
but really there is no debate here why
does this matter well knowing that
Gotham is roughly New York tells us a
lot especially about where Batman is
going with the bomb if Batman is
starting in Manhattan we know that
there's only one direction you can go
over Manhattan into the water Sal with
that we now know Batman's trajectory and
all that's left is for us to pinpoint
the area 3.1 miles off the coast and
figure out what would happen if you
detonated a four kiloton nuclear bomb
there
fortunately modeling a nuclear bomb is
incredibly difficult remember there are
a lot more factors in a dirty bomb than
a regular explosion there's the fireball
which is what creates the mushroom cloud
that we associate with all the old
footage of nuclear bombs then there's
the physical blast radius which is the
actual shockwave that blasts through
buildings and breaks glass and finally
there's the nuclear fallout which can
travel massive distances and cause
damage for years decades to come luckily
I don't have to model out this explosion
on my own because the Internet can do it
for me believe it or not there's a site
called nuke project that raises
awareness for how destructive nuclear
weapons are that actually lets you model
the damage a nuke would cause anywhere
in the world yeah this is one of those
nightmare fuel websites don't to play
with this one before going to bed or in
the airport like we were when we were
working on this episode I've got to be
on some watch list somewhere at this
point anyway you can't put in every
factor but we can put in a few including
where the bomb goes off and how much it
weighs we know that the blast radius
will already be 6 miles and the model
tells us that close to the center of the
blast we're looking at a 50 to 90
percent mortality rate so what happens
at 3.1 miles offshore buildings in
Jersey City Brooklyn and Staten Island
would instantly collapse everyone from
the bottom of Staten Island to northern
Manhattan would have third-degree
radiation burns even though the fireball
would be mostly contained in the water
our model does show that almost six
thousand people are going to die
immediately with another two hundred and
forty five thousand people being injured
from collapsed buildings and radiation
it's important to remember to the bum
doesn't have to go off in the water for
that to happen the most famous
devastating nuclear explosions like the
one in Hiroshima
didn't happen with the bomb on the
ground it happened when the bomb
exploded 600 meters above ground level
just like in our scenario with Batman
the bomb exploded in midair which was
actually more destructive than it might
have been on the ground according to
this simulation even structures that
weren't destroyed would take damage as
far as Queens and northern Manhattan all
the windows and car windshields in lower
Manhattan would break the Empire State
Building would literally sway and the
Chrysler Building would have floors of
broken glass people would die across
three boroughs of the city and believe
me I'm not saying any of this lightly
this is incredibly scary stuff and it
gets worse when a nuclear reaction
doesn't have any shield it creates
what's known as fallouts maybe you've
heard of this they've made a really
obscure video game series about it I
don't know in a very basic sense nuclear
fallout is residual radioactive material
that's blown into the atmosphere that
falls out of the sky after the explosion
and shockwave are gone in our model the
fallout from this explosion will go the
way the wind is blowing or water is
flowing luckily most of the water flows
out to the ocean along with the rest of
the tin cans and dead bodies that are
floating in the East River pretty much
most of the time anyway and I say
luckily with a huge grain of salt that
radiation is going to contaminate the
ocean for years and with it all sea life
which will eventually make its way back
to humanity but what we're most
interested in is the wind the wind is a
whole nother story in Manhattan wind
patterns could carry radioactive dust
ash or even black rain literal literal
black rain rain that is black all the
way up the island and out into as far as
Connecticut and don't think you'll
escape it by taking a weekend at the Han
Compton's because this stuff can
literally last for years cancer rates in
the city would potentially skyrocket
from the air and radioactive drinking
water and child birth defects would show
up all over Manhattan not that you'd be
able to get out of the city anyway
remember in this scenario there are no
bridges intact out of the city and no
way to evacuate Manhattan everyone is
gonna be there stuck in lockdown in a
radioactive field for weeks and here you
thought the Dark Knight trilogy was dark
before but let's rewind and see if there
was anything that could have been done
to save the thousands of Gotham lives
that were lost believe it or not all of
this could have been avoided let's say
the Batman doesn't waste the 42 seconds
on goodbyes with Catwoman or this
tearful farewell with Commissioner
Gordon I mean they don't even make sense
anyway it's not like he kills himself he
ends up with Selina Kyle and could have
just sent Commissioner Gordon a postcard
saying hey sup I was Batman the whole
time psych so let's say that instead of
wasting time that could have been spent
you know disposing of a massive nuclear
bomb Batman actually I don't know did
his job and used all that time to haul
away the bomb a little bit further now
he has a whole other 42 seconds to
travel at top speed in the bat copter so
bringing back our first model he now has
81 seconds over the water more than
double what he was doing before doing
the math that would put Batman safely at
6.6 miles away from the coast now
outside the blast radius with room to
spare
in this scenario Batman almost clears
the outer boroughs and we still have
about a thousand casualties but deaths
have been reduced by 75% injuries are
reduced 83% to about 24,000 which is
still a lot but it's happening in
boroughs that are much easier to
evacuate and keeps Manhattan almost
completely intact if we give him our
super scenario where he isn't slowed
down at all he can actually get a
whopping nine point five miles away well
out into the ocean where yes the bomb is
still gonna take out a lot of fish but
humanity will actually be saved with
zero casualties and no injuries based on
the model the extra 42 seconds Batman
should have spent in the air host Gotham
over 4
thousand deaths and literally hundreds
of thousands of injuries all of them
could have been saved if Batman had just
kept it in his pants or his rubberized
codpiece but hey that's just a theory
all film theory and cut